[Music]
what is it like returning to a character
um after for a season two and how do you
sort of get ready for that first day of
filming
are you re-watching some episodes or is
it more just mental
mentally getting ready it was like we
did we had a long weekend
and then we all came back and you have
all of the support of
a lot of the same crew and people around
you and it's like you're going back
to work and we're quite literally
picking up where we left off and um
it it felt very possible because of
everybody's incredible
abilities and professionalism and uh
yeah i don't know it felt like
slipping on the comfortable pair of
shoes and
walking yeah but also i mean you know
that
after the we've done the show you know
you go back and you do
adr and you might do some reshoots and
then
you go and do a press tour and you kind
of usually if that's a film
that that's your kind of farewell you
know is that premiere but
yeah as lauren said it was like we had a
long weekend and we came straight back
and
literally we start season two directly
where we left off so yeah it was like i
we just seen one another it was not that
long ago and
we were right back to work and then of
course we had the pandemic and six-month
gap but even that six-month gap when we
came back
it was it's comforting to to go back and
play the
the same character with such good
writing you know how do you actually
tease season two
without saying anything because there's
so much i would like to talk about but
it would just ruin this
the show so how have you been like
telling people about season two
well for me i've just been talking about
like dorothy turns away from
the vulnerability of the the trauma and
not you know not facing what happened
into a very real problem and comes into
her
strength and power and there because of
that
there are some really scary moments and
scary
uh scenes with with leanne especially in
the power struggle that they
they get into and um that was really
shocking to me
to read and uh scary
to perform but ultimately pretty fun
where lauren and nell's characters go is
is insane and then
the kind of the spiral of rupert's
character and how that develops
for sean it was it was nice that we had
a real problem to deal with it was nice
that they'd given us that
so now there is a real issue and of
course the baby's gone and
as is the person we both suspect has
taken that baby you know
uh leanne nell's character so
there's a real thing that we get to deal
with so it gives us back our
relationship in a way it builds that
bridge back
in that we're not back to who we were
but we actually have to communicate and
there's a real kind of
urgency that i don't pity dorothy over i
don't go
oh poor deluded the baby's gone you know
why are you not out there doing this
thing why are you not going out what is
that thing so
it gives sean a reason to start to look
for for questions
that have answers because his whole
cynical nature from before that he knows
everything is not gonna
wash with this new problem but of course
then he also
it's layered because now he's got to
keep the authorities away from
from the insanity that starts to get
more and more out of hand within the
house
i don't think that reveals anything no
that was great
um one of the things about this series
is that every time i watch an episode it
just makes me want to drink wine
uh because there's the amazing seller
and everyone's drinking wine like
non-stop did you guys
leave do you leave set and like bring me
the bottle
100 yeah we're all raging yeah raging
heavy drink
no i'm tired of grape juice this season
like we've got pomegranate juice as if i
was supposed to be like oh
amazing thank goodness we have a
different type of juice
yeah i um i'm glad shawn was supposed to
gain some weight this season
because uh the amount i had to eat the
amount of takes where i'm eating where i
had to just
stuff my face repeatedly and
swallow gallons and gallons of fruit
juice
um i think i'm made of high fructose
corn syrup at the moment so
uh yeah it was a lot it was a lot it is
a lot and yes
apologies for the amount it makes you
want to drink but the wine is so fine
and the cellar's my favorite place i
mean it's just my favorite place to go
even on set you know between takes i go
down there there's so many good cookery
books to read and
you know stuff to do so i'm bored i just
revealed i'm boring and old
um how much do you know ultimately of
where it's all going to go
because knight has said he knows where
the series is going to end and how much
do you sort of enjoy getting it script
by script
yeah i mean that's the it's i i trust
knight to
to have a really strong ending and
i and and help us you know
carve away and tell this mysterious
story as we go
um and that's i mean that ultimately
that's kind of the fun of it
we we do our best to bring
to bring the human element to the show
and
and the you know in the scene that we
know what's going on in that scene
and um there's so much more to the show
than than
what even is on the page so so it
it makes sense yeah i mean
day to day it's such a creative group
there's so much creativity going into it
people looking after us overseeing it
all apple's such a creative company you
know there's so much but i think
knight thrives on knowing what you don't
know
he's like i think you know so he he
loves that and i think that that shows
in the genre he kind of carved out for
himself
um knowing what you've done is his gig
so
yeah i'm happy knowing you know scene by
scene script by script so
yeah knowing where we're going is not my
goal it's uh making sure it's authentic
doing my part because there's so many
talented people in the crew as lauren
said in the crew
in every department you know the house
is so beautifully done as we've said so
many times before you know the
the effects everything you know the
camera work you know there's just
fantastic artists all the way through
this um
it's just really a pleasure to to get to
be one of those
in a team i gotta go on that note
congrats on this
this season um i can't wait to finish it
uh good luck with the rest of your speed
dating
same to you steve